so
first of all
how do you get started
the first program that we're going to
discuss is called introduction to
bioinformatics so if you have minimal
background with bioinformatics you don't
really have any experience maybe you
have read and you have heard and you're
interested in it but you don't really
have any practical experience
this is the best place to start
now you will be able to register for
multiple programs for example you can
take introduction to bioinformatics
first and then once you complete it you
can go on to the more advanced programs
those advanced programs could include
all three of the other programs genomics
metagenomics or data science
but first for those that don't have any
background we recommend
getting started with this introductory
program
now this introductory program includes
several modules and these are
introduction to bioinformatics
bytes and molecules bioinformatics and r
and bioinformatics and python so this
will really orient you with some
terminology and some basic skills for
you to get started it is typically
something that you can complete about in
about a month's time so that's why we're
offering for those that complete
introduction to bioinformatics to
continue on to the more advanced
programs
as soon as you have registered you will
already have access to all of these
materials some of them are completely
free
and some of them will have some free
modules that you can just test and see
if that's something that you would like
to do
so these are found and again i'll just
quickly switch here to the portal
once you're logged in
sorry
so once you're logged in for example
this is my profile
you can see here information about
myself and then if i click right here on
courses
i can scroll or search or right here you
will see getting started so if you click
on getting started
you will see these modules that i was
just showing on the screen introduction
to bioinformatics bytes and molecules
bioinformatics and r and bioinformatics
and python so these are some of the
starting materials that we will cover
now beyond that what we will do in the
program
is we will use these basic modules to
see the applications of bioinformatics
to learn about the terminology that is
commonly used with bioinformatics
methods we're going to do a little
introduction to coding with python and r
just so that you're aware of what goes
into some of these methods of analysis
and then we will provide you with access
to some introductory projects so these
projects are going to show you how
people that have used bioinformatics in
a variety of domains like infectious
diseases oncology and others
have been able to use the mess the
methods that we cover in these programs
to achieve research results so what
actually went in there so the way you
can find those is first of all there's
the search field you can search for
example for ebola
or you can look over here on tags and
these tags include some typical
types of materials that you will find
and down here we have organized them
into these
sections sections for getting started
sections in r sections in python
projects etc
so the one we just discussed was getting
started which is right here
now beyond that
once you are getting comfortable with
how things are organized and you
understand how to navigate the site
you'll be able to find a lot of
additional materials that you can just
try and do on your own asynchronously
so let's talk briefly about this uh
online logic programs in general first
and then we'll jump into introduction to
bioinformatics
so as a part of this initiative we have
collected materials from a variety of
researchers
that address these specific types of
applications of bioinformatics first of
all introduction a general overview of
bioinformatics genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics epigenomics and data
science
these will be offered throughout the
year including in the summer a specific
program around
a research fellowship and this research
fellowship will provide you with an
opportunity to work on an independent
project so the idea here is to provide
training with basic skills and then to
offer a variety of applications
including oncology
uh infectious diseases neuroscience
agriculture biotechnology and others
so what typically goes into a training
program like this
are a collection of resources that we
will be providing
for those that participate so first of
all you will have access to the training
materials those training materials will
be completely asynchronous you will be
able to find them on this portal but you
will also have a program page that will
organize these materials into a sequence
once you complete each one of those you
will also be sent a video that you can
watch that explains how the different
elements of this program are combined
together you will also have access to a
big data analysis platform that you can
use to analyze
public domain data and some of those
public domain data sets are going to be
explained in the materials that you will
be provided you will also find elements
of code that you can get started with to
apply what you have learned in r and
python
and some explanations on how to do that
so what does the syntax mean what does
it do some examples that you can try
right in the browser and an explanation
of how you can take that and use it on
your own system
now the previous programs that we have
run
we try to address the needs of those
that want to learn about but also apply
what they have learned to their current
research
and to project sometimes citizen science
projects sometimes research projects and
we have quite a number of people that
were successful at completing the
program and learning about how to apply
these methods
in their uh
research
that they were a part of
so what we um want to cover in this
first program the introduction to
bioinformatics is to provide a general
overview to those that don't have a lot
of experience already with
bioinformatics so this will
include
bioinformatics and big data how big data
and the need for computational
technologies is changing bioinformatics
including an introduction to a variety
of omics types of data
and then two methods of analysis the
basic statistical analysis as well as
machine learning for a variety of these
types of objects data
we will touch on
the scripting aspect but that will
really be minimal it's not intended to
be
in-depth about any one particular
language or application it's really to
provide you with the sense of what
bioinformatics is and how to apply it in
a general theoretical sense and so
hopefully this is something that anyone
with any background can participate in
and benefit from just learning about the
terminology so the three main things
that we will cover are informatics
statistics and biology and so what that
means is that we will talk a little bit
about what kinds of information
technologies uh what kinds of
statistical and analytical methods and
what kinds of applications of
bioinformatics
are important to understanding and how
that is changing different fields where
bioinformatics is used so primarily we
will try to talk about this from the
perspective of
biology and data so how does data
describe biology and how can we study
biological phenomena using different
types of data
that provide us with this detailed view
of what's going on
but we will also talk about the
applications of bioinformatics in
clinical
and different industry projects as well
specifically in biomedical application
to diagnostics and selection of
therapeutics or discovery of
therapeutics and things like that
now we
will cover several different types of
omics
including genomics epigenomics and
transcriptomics
but very superficially so there won't be
any in-depth explanation in this
particular introduction to
bioinformatics program it is just going
to provide you with the sense of what
does this data describe and what does
this data look like
to understand what it looks like we're
going to also cover several publicly
available data repositories where you
can explore projects that have been
submitted by uh researchers across many
different types of labs and you will be
able to find a variety of different
project examples that are typically
associated with a publication so
hopefully you will find some relevance
to whatever field you're involved in
now as i mentioned one of the challenges
in bioinformatics is being able to not
only learn about bioinformatics but
practically experience what
bioinformatics can do for you and so to
introduce you to different methods of
analysis of bioinformatics we have a
platform called the t binocular platform
that is color coded with explained
methods that allows for a variety of
inputs and outputs and really will
provide you with a guided process to
understand the logic of bioinformatics
so for those that are getting started
this is the best way to go from
general understanding to practical
application quickly right and hopefully
that also reinforces the logic of why am
i doing what i'm doing and what am i
expecting to get out of this
uh process that we call a pipeline or a
workflow
so to summarize the introduction to
bioinformatics program is going to
explain how big data is used in
bioinformatics or biomedical research we
will talk briefly about
sorry we will talk briefly about the
applications of bioinformatics
there we go
different types of technologies
and some concepts of data science that
are going to be useful as you continue
to explore what bioinformatics can offer
and so to see a detailed curriculum
you can find the detailed curriculum on
this landing page and so
i'll just show you this landing page and
i'll paste the link here as well
so you can find this information right
here
on this link
so if you scroll down
you will find here the full syllabus so
if you have any questions about the
syllabus and what it includes please
don't hesitate to reach out to us but
this is uh the full overview of the
program again it's fairly short but it's
going to be
good for those that are just getting
started with bioinformatics so this
program we ran it in the previous
semester as well we have quite a number
of people of students including graduate
and undergraduate students that have
completed this program and it really can
take a biologist somebody that knows
nothing about bioinformatics and help
them understand
why they should learn this or how to
apply it and at least will be useful to
read some papers that include
bioinformatics or if you're going to
submit a grant and you're going to
incorporate bioinformatics will provide
you with better terminology to interact
with your
bioinformatics core and kind of let them
understand what exactly you're trying to
do
so the other programs again these were
beginner programs the other programs
that we're going to talk about are
project oriented so project oriented
means that we're expecting those that
have completed the other type of
training not the introduction to
bioinformatics program but genomics
meta-genomics and data science to be
able to submit
to learn skills that will allow them to
produce a project of their own and
that's really the best validation that
you're able to apply what you have
learned and we hope that you can do it
in a fairly short time
so to do that part of this omixlogic
portal
is an opportunity to
once you complete your profile to be
able to submit a project right on the
learn portal
and apply what you have learned in this
training to a data set describing
everything that there was to
that you did and really focusing on
reproducible research so as you complete
your profile and you learn by acquiring
points by completing different course
work then you will be able to submit
this
project that we
that i will explain in a second but
that's the major differentiation between
what we call a basic program and an
advanced program so the fans programs
are really oriented for those that want
to use this